a report has just been received of a
woman threatening to kill herself
a team is dispatched to deal with the
emergency what we're responding to is a
female spotted a female who was caught
little are Waystation going on she's
gone missing from the family only to die
our intention is to step in front of a
railway line
so we've commonly got British Transport
Police officers with her aware on note
now to make sure that we can safeguard
her RIA sort of it get getting back to a
family as quick as possible in the
unmarked ambulance in front of us is a
police officer a paramedic and a
psychiatric nurse three services dealing
with one crisis together
so what you'll notice returned it like
the signs off as we approach because the
station is not far away
so it helps to just make sure we try not
to do it unless we after she being held
in the back of that car yeah
the woman is transferred to the
ambulance where the paramedic carries
out a full physical examination at the
same time the mental health nurse is
evaluating her patients
there should be starting to get some
details starting to understand a little
bit about history starting to understand
exactly what's occurring today so the
police officer is almost redundant now
yeah absolutely
but what the the interesting bit around
this is actually they might be redundant
but if this girl then decides to walk
away then the mental health nurse or the
primary think I've got no power to stop
that right so suppose there's a police
officer being called to this 12 months
ago before the triage team our immediate
action probably would have been to
detain into the Mental Health Act
because they were intent on doing
something some harm to themselves go
straight to a prison cell structures
police cell or to a place of safety
it's decided the woman is a danger to
herself but instead of taking her to a
police cell she's brought to a secure
mental health unit for more care
she was quite sort of reluctant to
engage with us initially she was very
distressed and here for but she was
communicating that she was having
thoughts to end her life and so that was
enough to concern us to bring her here
for a further assessment about three
years ago she was under services she had
contact then and she was diagnosed with
a psychotic depression so that
information is really useful when you go
into an assessment because you can kind
of know what signs and symptoms you're
looking for you'll see one of the
on-call doctors one of the psychiatrists
will come and have a further chat with
her and together they'll formulate a
plan of care
it's another success with a team and the
triage project introduced here in the
West Midlands Police Force last year
the approach has already produced some
big results the most important one is
the dramatic reduction in police
detention under Section 136 of the
Mental Health Act
essentially criminalizing someone who is
sick and in need of care the number of
detentions were actually reduced you now
I mean we've seen a 51 percent reduction
in the number of people detained I mean
that's over 300 people within buildings
on the hill in the last 12 months so
that's really really significant
we've also stopped nearly 700 people
being admitted to A&E because the way
that our process works with the
paramedic means of physical health can
be dealt with by the paramedic in lots
of circumstances now but the achievement
of the West Midlands Police Force is
rare policing mental health is a huge
challenge and many forces are struggling
to cope especially in areas where mental
health care budgets are underfunded the
scandal was exposed in November last
year a 16 year old girl with a history
of serious self-harm was brought into a
custody suite to protect her until a
secured hospital bed could be found she
ended up being held for three days and
two nights but the strongest
condemnation came from within the same
police force that had arrested and
detained the girl a cyst --nt Chief
Constable Paul Netherton shocked and
distressed by what was happening took to
social media it is unacceptable that we
have a suicidal young person being kept
in police custody overnight and and in
this case for three days in you know in
a place which is full of drunk and
aggressive and violent individuals to
have someone who's suicidal in that
who's unacceptable when I was a young
police officer it was all about catching
criminals of burglars and car thieves
now my officers are spending about 20
percent of their time dealing with
either the the after-effects of mental
health issues or dealing with people
suffering from mental health episodes I
sense from listening to you and other
police officers that there is the sense
of frustration that you've talked about
but certainly there is a tension between
the police force and the other services
health care providers is that a fair
assessment do you think there is and
certainly over the last few years that
tension has been growing we're all in
austerity we understand that the problem
is is that the government funded the
health service to provide certainly the
establishments for these people to go to
the challenge for the health services
they've got to provide the staff to
staff them and look after the patients
and they they simply are having to make
very tough choices the view of the
police services well I understand that
but actually it's never right that these
patients are coming in to police
premises and we're having to look after
them when we haven't got the skills we
haven't got the facilities and to be
frankly honest to custody block is not
where you should put someone who is
suicidal
I spoke to the mother of the girl and
although she has nothing but praise for
a CC Paul Netherton and his force
she's clearly distraught at the failure
to care for her sick child she would
have been very scared then she would
have had to obviously hear whatever was
going on in the other cells the drugs
coming in on the Friday night and the
same again on the Saturday night and no
I think she would have been scared I
know she was asleep a lot of the time
because of the medication so I'm hoping
she wasn't damaged too much by it
because like I say a lot of the time she
was asleep the girl was moved to three
different locations following her
detention the family spent Christmas on
the road traveling from one facility to
the other
now she's being held at a hospital in
Norwich but her family lives in Devon on
the other side of the country most
people accept she could get better
sooner if she had her family nearby but
no suitable beds are available how much
effort does it take for you to get some
water oh it takes a lot of effort and
money and time yeah but I do it because
she's my daughter and I love her
I don't see her I've seen her twice
since Christmas she needs us and when we
are with her it's amazing because all
the staff are saying how well my
daughter is doing and how she needs to
be near her family but it's crazy
because she's so far away and now I'm
having to fight for my child to just get
what she needs and to get to get better
the bed shortage is one symptom of a
mental health system in crisis
another is the need for more safe spaces
otherwise police forces across the
country will have no choice but to
continue criminalizing society's most
vulnerable are shoosh Joshy Sky News